wow so morbius is out
finally and before we talk about the
sony comic book movie event of two years
ago gonna give some love to the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by
nordvpn nordvpn's vpn service that looks
to help you navigate this digital
wonderland minefield we call the
internet more safely so let's face it
whether you're on the internet for
business pleasure we're all on the
internet i mean look at this video now i
appreciate the fact that nordvpn blocks
malware written websites scans
downloaded files for viruses like i've
said before i'm a huge retro gamer
continually tweaking optimizing in the
quest to perfect that setup and such a
quest to optimize that home brew will
take you to websites you know nothing
about to download files you hope or save
so nordvpn being that kind of buffer
that kind of shield i really appreciate
that plus with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee you know i love me that kind
of peace of mind so click the link below
go to nordvpn.com
john's get yourself a two-year plan with
a huge discount plus one additional
month for free and thank you once again
to nordvpn for sponsoring this video i
do appreciate it and now that i just got
back from seeing the movie did i call it
the sony comic book movie event two
years ago it's
well it's something it is
here we go
so morbius stars al madrigal he plays a
cop he's investigating a series of
murders in which people's blood have
been drained from it doesn't it should
have he was the best part of the movie
now this actually stars jared leto as
michael morbius it's a film adaptation
of the character michael morbius he has
a blood condition in this movie he's
worked his entire life trying to find a
cure he finds that cure that cure turns
him into a living vampire this movie is
supposed to come out a couple years ago
and then lockdown now no one really
cares and there was a big red flag here
you see the embargo drop you see all
these reviews drop at the same time
right the embargo for the reviews lifted
about 12 hours before the public could
see this movie could mean one of a
couple things one they have the biggest
comic book movie reveal bombshell in
history in this movie they don't michael
keaton's in the trailer he's not even in
the movie he could have been in the
post-credits scene that may or may not
have been in this movie i didn't stay
for it i didn't care it didn't give a
[ __ ] or two the studio knows this
movie's terrible they don't want you to
know until you're in the movie theater
watching the movie no jared leto as
michael morbius he was fine you know at
this point i'm kind of
sick of making excuses for jared leto
but as it stands as the character he's
fine i mean for someone who's known for
playing eccentric roles michael morbius
the living vampire is one of his least
eccentric roles in the past few years
that's the jared leto world we live in
the living vampire's the normal one but
when he is michael morbius dealing with
this thing that could have been more
interesting than it actually was a lot
of the stuff in his movies like the
concept is interesting execution
no that's when it's most interesting and
then you know he gets super monster face
and then cgi fights and it's much more
boring partly because this is the most
edited for television theatrically
released vampire movie i think i've ever
seen at first it was kind of there was a
story based reason for it because
michael morbius has come up with
synthetic blood you're like oh that's
interesting i have questions probably
more questions than i should
want to ask in a movie like this but
whatever but then it shifts from hey
we're showing how smart michael morbius
is to the real reason they have
synthetic blood it's because they can't
have michael morbius drinking real blood
because that is for
rated r movies i mean they're in those
blood transfusion donor bags you know
but it's blue blood that's not red blood
apparently someone in the higher ups of
sony felt that was more palatable for
pg-13 audience i don't know i wasn't in
the room but
i really think that's the reason because
if you wanted to show blood that doesn't
really work as well as pure human blood
you could have just had animal blood i
mean it's been done in a hundred vampire
movies before it's also more interesting
than fake blue blood more interesting
than macguffin blood that you make up to
make this movie less violent and even in
the action sequences when morbius at
first you know it's like morbius is out
now he's just living vampires beyond his
control he just shreds up a bunch of
people i used shred very loosely what i
mean is he slashes at them and you hear
the glug glug glug of blood like
like blood supposed to be coming out but
it's just not there i imagine they were
like yeah we'll fill it in with cgi
because rated r movie here we come oh
it's pg-13 sweet we can still do that we
can't i guess we'll keep the sound
effect of blood gushing and then just
not have it gush and have no blood on
screen at all there's even one scene
where it looks like he slashes somebody
but he doesn't really hit them and then
they were like
and i was like did he throw something on
them because they're in a lab after all
you know i thought he threw like here's
a pathogen but then after more
non-violent slashes of no blood but
there's supposed to be blood i was like
no i was pretty sure he slashed him and
they bled to death but didn't bleed it
off there's a little bit of blood there
are scenes where it's like oh
this blood i think you just bled to
death from what looks like a very
inconvenient cut yeah just it was weird
it was weirdly edited i mean from the
get-go from the intro of this movie
they're clearly just
throwing a bunch of information at you
in the shortest amount of time possible
and that usually doesn't bode well a
movie usually feels rushed when they do
that with their setup and just so is the
case here but the thing is it doesn't
stop there are pacing issues throughout
this movie i get it pacing you gotta
thread the needle man there's this
goldilocks zone when it comes to pacing
if it rushes by too quickly scenes don't
have enough time to marinade then it
just seems like a bunch of scenes that
are stitched together feels sloppy feels
rushed feels like morbius but if it
drags on too long movie feels boring
audience starts getting restless the
thing here
is i really think this movie was
supposed to be a two hour movie you can
see it in here you're like this the
scene is edited
to again have a bunch of information
thrown at you in about two minutes in
fact watching this movie i was like this
looks like it'd be a really sweet video
game where you become a vampire and you
start figuring out your powers but if it
is morbius it would be a video game
based off of a movie and those usually
are
what's the word
ass so you know probably not but even as
a video game you know in video games
when you drink a potion or something
it's the same animation every time
that's how video games usually are
that's how this movie was you know he
would drink the blood bag every time
this was what he did
every time same thing same reaction no
variance whatsoever then when the fights
happen there's this other cgi
monster-faced person that morbius has to
fight it's not really in the trailer so
i'm keeping it vague but
when you're watching the movie you're
gonna be like oh
this movie being predictable as it is
know exactly how it's going down but
when they're fighting you know what
i can't qualify whether or not the
fighting was good at all because i
couldn't see it all i saw were two
bodies zoomed into the two bodies and
then debris and tumbling and i saw
things about this clearly it's just cgi
mess that's what it is 90 minute cgi
mess
should have said that in the intro it's
more apt this movie just kind of reminds
me of one of the bad comic book movies
from an earlier age of comic book movies
you know when comic book movies just
felt like this kind of schlock no one
really cared because comic book movies
were niche they weren't like the
spearhead
changing the way movies are made or
perceived there were these weird things
that nerds like me were like i hope this
one's good oh it's not okay i mean there
were some gems in there but you know
what i'm saying the only thing is we've
seen so much more at this point and
there are studios doing it so much
better it might be a little harsh to
call it dog [ __ ] but i'm gonna do it
anyway a living vampire and a lifeless
movie
that is ironic alright morbius have you
seen it don't worry 12 hours from now
you can because the studio knows the
movie is ass but did you even know it
was coming out did you forget about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
how's my hair
is it good